[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui
est louche ice est l'ambassadeur de la
république populaire de chine en france
merci d'être avec nous monsieur
l'ambassadeur
bonjour nous sommes à moins de trois
semaines des jeux olympiques d'hiver qui
doivent débuter à pékin alors il y a un
souci comme dans le monde entier mais
évidemment les yeux sont sur pékin c'est
celui de la pandémie de qu'ovide ce
lundi le nombre de cas a atteint son
plus haut niveau depuis mars 2020 en
chine avec 223 cas on sait que le
variant omicron est désormais présent à
pékin alors une question toute simple
est ce que les jeux olympiques sont
menacés par une recrudescence de la
pandémie
alors la chine est maintenant tout à
fait prête pour accueillir les athlètes
différents pays du monde et offrir une
édition des jeux olympiques d'hiver
merveilleuse splendide
en ce qui concerne l'épidémie
effectivement récemment la chine a
dénombré et de helvetas pratique oracle
mais par rapport à la situation
internationale
la situation en chine qu'aux vite et
très bien contrôlable et maintenant une
une centaine quelques deux sauts
ça ne sera pas grand chose nous avons
déjà beaucoup d'expérience de contrôler
mais on a vu récemment des villes
entières on pense à chian par exemple
qui ont été mis sous cloche si je peux
dire juste avec quelques cas est ce que
c'est une possibilité pour pékin si
jamais il ya une recrudescence des cas
en raison de l'arrivée des athlètes des
délégations ou en raison d'une
contamination locale est ce que ça c'
est envisagée alors
les jo
la partie chinoise en collaboration avec
le cio a édifié des mesures de
prévention pour la peau vide les sites
fonctionneront ensuite fermé pendant les
jeux et des équipes de soutien
logistique et médicale donc déjà à pied
d'oeuvre en ce qui concerne sheehan oui
effectivement on a fait un confinement à
ciel mais c'est nécessaire bien pour
bien coupé le circuit du virus et on a
vu le résultat
quelques jours
le nombre de cas total des apc largement
et donc ça pourrait être utilisé à pékin
pendant les jeux si jamais ça se produit
ou c'est totalement exclu
cela dit paul pense que maintenant au
moins pour le moment appétit il n'y a
pas beaucoup de cas seulement il me
paraît en tant qu on a mis des il ya
quelques jours mais c est très bien
pisté situer donc
on n'a pas besoin de s'inquiéter quand
j'en suis sur deux
dans la période des jeux il y aura pas
grande comment dire épidémie qu'on vite
appétit
les sur un point de vue plus
diplomatiques plusieurs pays les états
unis le canada l'australie est désormais
le danemark ont décrété ce qu'on appelle
un boycott diplomatique pour protester
contre la situation des droits de
l'homme notamment dans la région du
xinjiang
est ce que vous craignez que d'autres
pays se joignent à ce boycott
diplomatique ou est ce que pour vous ça
vous est totalement indifférent
alors les jeux olympiques sont
organisées pour les athlètes sportifs
de tous les pays du monde pas pour les
politiciens de certains pays alors
qu'ils viennent ou pas
ça n'a rien à voir avec le pontet où le
mot des jeux olympiques d'ailleurs leur
prétexte
le soi-disant
des problèmes et en chine tiens est basé
tout à fait sûr les manceaux
et si jamais des athlètes eux-mêmes sur
place décident de manifester sur le
xinjiang ou sur le tibet quelle sera la
réaction de pékin ni il y a les règles
bol du theil au donc
sur les sites et jeux olympiques il faut
maintenir la neutralité politique
alors je veux en venir à la situation
dans la région et notamment avec taïwan
le ministre des affaires étrangères
taiwan a déclaré sur nos antennes ya
quelques jours je le cite que la menace
militaire de pékin était très sérieuse
le président chinois vient de déclarer
qu'il craint les conséquences
catastrophiques d'une confrontation
mondiale monsieur l'ambassadeur est ce
qu'on est proche où on se rapproche
dangereusement d'une guerre tout d'abord
je dois
paris fier et heureux d'avoir fait
partie intégrale du territoire chinois
donc à taiwan il n'y a pas de ministre
des affaires étrangères ce monsieur là
ce qu'il dit c'est tout à fait faux et
infondé
maintenant ce n'est pas la question
comment dire de réunification harnais
c'est la question de ce que les
autorités taïwanaises et séparatistes et
one elles ne doivent pas faire des
actions de provocation pour
augmenter la tension de la situation du
détroit de taiwan est ce que vous
considérez que ce sont eux qui multiplie
les provocations parce que ils disent
que c'est vous qui clairement dit
vouloir une réunification pacifique mais
en fait que c'est vous qui vous préparer
à la guerre et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
besoin du soutien notamment des états
unis
alors la réunification de la patrie et
la mission pour le peuple chinois y
compris le peuple la loi n'est pas loin
fait partie de la fait partie intégrale
aller avec palau 2 la chine depuis les
temps anciens
donc
en chine nous avons une loi pour
prévenir la séparation pays donc si les
autorités taïwanaises continue à faire
la provocation pour augmenter la tension
donc
là le gouvernement chinois au mot fèvre
la réaction
comment dire
pertinentes et
les états unis n'ont pas joué un rôle
positif au dans cette affaire c'est 800
mots durs le soutien des américains que
les autorités rwandaises aux avances et
plus en plus vers le sens du salle izzo
d'indépendants
quand vous dites la chine prendra toutes
les mesures pertinentes pour qu'on soit
bien d'accord est-ce que ça inclut
les moyens militaires si vous les jugez
nécessaire ou est ce que vous dites non
la réunification sera pacifique quelles
que soient les conditions nous on trime
haut sur la réunification a rêvé essieux
passif est d'ailleurs voyez que le guen
monchy noire
a sorti beaucoup de mesures pour
promouvoir la coopération
économique
inter dans inter détroit dans la région
des deux rives du détroit et c'est pour
pas mal iran ont demandé l élever le
bien-être un déficit les bénéfices du
peuple taïwanais mais on ne peut pas
laisser à wall ceux de se séparer
donc on n'a pas renoncé
non recours à la force c'est pas visé le
peuple à whalley mais pour dissuader les
séparatistes appelle moi et certains de
force et roger alors taïwan a récemment
ouvert un bureau en lituanie au sein de
l'union européenne qui porte le nom de
taïwan et non pas le nom habituel de
taipei suite à ça la chine a rétrogradé
ses relations diplomatiques avec la
lituanie l'union européenne vous accuse
d'avoir pris des mesures de rétorsion
commerciale contre la lituanie mais la
chine n'est pas allé jusqu'à rompre les
relations diplomatiques avec la lituanie
est ce que c'est parce que vous avez
peur de ce que ça pourrait déclencher
vis-à-vis de l'union européenne
alors l'union européenne observe une
politique d'une seule chine vis-à-vis de
la chine
l'action de lituanie va à l'encontre de
la politique de
unis de l'union européenne donc lituanie
a créé et difficultés à l'union
européenne ne pouvait mon chinois a
fédéré un os
pertinent pertinente parce que nous
devons nous devons comment dire
faire respecter le principe d'une seule
chine à tous les pays ico et relations
diplomatiques avec nous et bien sûr
matinaux la chine a happé c'est
seulement le niveau des relations
diplomatiques avec la lituanie on n'a
pas rompu et pourquoi pas vous avez peur
de la réaction européenne
c'est sympa la peur la peur mais tu es
pour exprimer notre position ferme
de s'opposer de nous opposer
comment dire à la mise à mal
ainsi peu seule chine dame est quand
même la chine considère toujours
l'habitude ali le peuple italien
comme d'autres familles oui nous
espérons que le gouvernement
elles corrigent leurs fautes pour
revenir sur la position correcte
dernière question monsieur l'ambassadeur
on parle de peut-être négociations entre
taiwan et l'union européenne d'accords
commerciaux économiques est ce que pour
vous ce serait une ligne rouge si jamais
ces accords étaient négocier
éventuellement conclu nous nous opposons
à ce que tous les pays ou bien le groupe
de pays
ayant relations diplomatiques avec nous
de mener et comportent des échéances
officielles avec les autorités palois
donc si si jamais ils le font pour vous
c'est une ligne rouge
nous nous opposons à ce que les
autorités taïwanaises
font des axiaux sa peau les relations
entre la chine et l'union européenne
monsieur l'ambassadeur louchats et merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu aux questions
de france 24
et merci à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien sur nos antennes restez-y pour
plus d'informations
[Musique]